the news that Noam Chomsky hung out with
the late Jeffrey Epstein has really sent
many people for quite a loop uh Chomsky
was asked about this and said none of
your business when the Wall Street
Journal inquired about it which is
striking at least some people in my
audience as a very strange response it's
the entire thing is not incredibly
newsworthy but I think what is setting
some people off is what they perceive to
be a really like the worst possible
response from gnome Chomsky now of
course Jeffrey Epstein
um who is now deceased uh now understood
to be an extraordinary Predator
involving uh young girls and you know
all the the details are so beyond the
scope of what I can um
uh sort of illuminate here but this has
been an ongoing story for a very very
long time uh and he is an
extraordinarily uh horrifying predator
and so every time it turns out someone
met with him this happened to Bill Gates
Trump and Clinton knew Epstein it it
always sort of generates a little bit of
a story but uh Alan dershowitz is
another one who visited
um Jeffrey Epstein's Private Island I
believe it was but Chomsky is surprising
some so there's a Business Insider story
renowned academic Noam Chomsky told the
Wall Street Journal that his meetings
with Jeffrey Epstein are quote none of
your business none of your business The
Wall Street Journal reports that Chomsky
held multiple meetings with Jeffrey
Epstein chomsky's meetings with Epstein
took place long after the disgraced
financier had registered as a sex
offender so the idea of this was long
before anybody knew anything not valid
it was it was known when the journal
asked Chomsky about the meetings the
linguist had some Choice words and the
article is it's a short article let's
look at it because it's interestingly
written when asked about their
connections with Jeffrey Epstein many
Business Leaders and bureaucrats offer
tight-lipped regrets and apologies not
Noam Chomsky The Wall Street Journal in
an exclusive published Sunday said it
obtained Epstein's private calendar it
outlined numerous meetings with
high-profile people including Chomsky
the famed academic and political
activist when the journal reached out to
Chomsky he had Choice words quote First
Response is that it is none of your
business or anyone's second is that I
knew him and we met occasionally Chomsky
94 told the journal in an email
Epstein the disgraced financier accused
of sex trafficking underage girls died
by suicide in 2019 in a Manhattan jail
as the awaited trial
um in addition to Chomsky the journal
noted meetings with a current CIA
director William Burns as well as
Catherine remler a top lawyer at Goldman
Sachs and former White House counsel
under Obama Epstein's meetings with
Chomsky appeared to have taken place in
2015 and 16. Epstein was first charged
with procuring minors for prostitution
and registered as a sex offender in
2008. in March of 2015 Epstein's
scheduled meetings was Chomsky and a
Harvard University Professor Chomsky
confirmed that there were several
meetings where they discussed various
topics the journal reported that months
later Epstein scheduled a flight with
Chomsky and his wife for a planned
dinner with movie director Woody Allen
and his wife Sun Yi Previn who is also
the adopted daughter of his ex-partner
Mia Farrow Chomsky said and this one is
a little weird if there was a flight
which I doubt it would have been from
Boston to New York 30 minutes see I
would remember whether I flew with
Jeffrey Epstein that I that's strange
but he says I'm unaware of the principle
that requires that I inform you about an
evening spent with a great artist
Chomsky said what was known about
Epstein was he had been convicted of a
crime and had served a sentence
according to U.S laws and Norms that
yields a clean slate so listen I agree
that the responses are a little bit odd
I also have no reason whatsoever to
believe that Chomsky did anything
inappropriate as it relates to the
things that Epstein was accused and
previously convicted of on the one hand
it would be really easy for Chomsky to
say listen Epstein contacted me to do
seminars for rich people because they
were interested in hearing my
perspective
um the the thing is if that's not true
why would Chomsky make that up and lie
if that's not actually what took place
and so I understand that Chomsky is
responding in what is sort of you know I
I you could say it's a strange response
but it also doesn't really suggest to me
that Chomsky did anything wrong
um I don't know that there's too much
more to say about it and quite frankly
it's not Ultra surprising to me and
listen if you had said hey David you
know knowing that Epstein met with
Clinton Trump and dershowitz who else
would you guess he might have hung out
with
my mind doesn't immediately go to
Chomsky but I do think it's important to
just kind of generally consider and
understand that
um it ends up being a small world in a
lot of ways and so when you say Chomsky
new Epstein it's not like a mind-blowing
shock to me at the same time if there's
any evidence at any point that comes
forward that Chomsky did anything wrong
we'll discuss it at this point there is
not